well I fight till I can't fight anymore
you know what I mean if a situation like
that happen you get hurt but I'm a
strong believer if you fight fight to
the end you know what I mean you don't
be afraid some guys get hit hard and
they they lay down cuz they don't want
to take a beating real fighter take
their beating like a man cuz Anything
Can Happen he's got h on but they'll
stop the fight there he goes at what
point did you know that you could be the
heavyweight champion 14 14 years old you
knew you were going you have to be the
champion before you become the champion
so that means lifestyle
have to be him before you become him you
got to be him before you become him